how often do you go back home
like home to alabama alabama i don't
ever go back for real there ain't
nothing to do out there
i mean [ __ ] is [ __ ] to do out there but
like i don't got nothing back there no
more
like i got no house i don't got no
friends or nothing
like all my like my homeboys and [ __ ]
they be coming out here right
like and when i go back home i getting a
hella [ __ ] i'm not scared of going
back home but it's like
smart man i know where to come with like
i'm making too much money to really put
myself in a situation
to where if i'm not going out there to
make no money i stay away from it [ __ ]
uh owen b peasy last year he got shot in
alabama shooting the video his own [ __ ]
you know what i mean like it's it's at
home where you got the biggest haters it
feels like
i mean [ __ ] i'm bulletproof with chunky
blower every time i go home but
it's really not i'm sorry not that i'm
sorry what does that mean
nothing but um this is like a chunky
blower is that a big gun
no okay but um is that a fat woman who
gives fellatio
nothing okay alabama bro it's just like
different food like
oh no i'll be in my backyard when i'm
home but [ __ ] i'm in
nigga's backyard too when i'm home right
it's like different i wasn't
you feel me i wasn't in everybody's
section i wasn't going every place like
that you feel me i was
doing my own little [ __ ] but when i go
back home it's
other people that come from them little
shits that know everything over there
so i was like why would i put myself in
that situation where i know i'm being a
downfall
and i'm not going to bring hella [ __ ]
with me and i'm going to want to just
visit my friends and [ __ ]
when i go back so i wouldn't even put
myself in a situation like that
where i have to really do something
cause i i'm gonna do something either
way like i'm not no
[ __ ] but yeah alabama just come with a
lot of [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ]